the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
okay good afternoon um so today we're
going to talk about learning so what can
you do now that you couldn't do as an
infant
very simply ha it has a good one
language that's pretty good right having
a feud anything else that you couldn't
do yeah yeah we don't have it actually
no what the internal mental life of an
infant likes but it doesn't seem like
they it remember many very specific
things about their lives you do but you
know it's a lot more you know you know a
ton of stuff a lot of facts right things
about the world values you hold about
your family your culture the country or
countries you've grown up in you just
know a ton compared to an infant and
there's only two ways that you know this
it's either in your genes when you're
born where you learned it through life
and so we're talk today about how you
know scientific psychology tries to
approach learning and a remarkable thing
about learning is we often think well
we're learning learning lessons or
whatever or learning material but the
important part of learning the way we
think about it is that it allows us to
predict the future on the basis of the
past right we want to learn lessons in
life to know what's desirable was
dangerous with a smart way to do things
so we're more effective we choose we
want to do better in the future to learn
from the past and predict the future it
imbues our word with meaning for an
infant not much means much right they
just look around
who knows what anything means words
gestures facial expressions there's not
much meaning of the world out there for
you the world is full of meaning history
social interactions everything that
you're thinking about so how do we
acquire the meanings of things in the
world that matter to us and it's also
had an interesting kind of a
give-and-take with how we learn about
learning in scientific psychology the
sort of historically I'll just touch a
tiny bit on that and we'll talk about
three aspects of learning today
classical conditioning operant
conditioning and then various ways in
which there are limits to conditioning
thank you Tyler
so let's talk you know with the sir one
of the most famous figures in all of a
conditioning or learning Yvonne Pavlov
who actually won a Nobel Prize not for
his studies of learning but for his
groundbreaking studies for the reflexes
repeated for the reflexes of digestion
he worked a lot of the fundamentals of
how in mammals your stomach breaks down
food and then how food in the mouth
provokes specific salivation that begins
the process by which food is decomposed
and and then digested in your stomach
the fundamentals of really how we live
right eat to live and he was very
interested in salivation reflexes what
is it that drives that first bit of
breaking down food in your mouth with
saliva and Pavlov was a - it was a
pretty intense researcher as you might
be used to at MIT there's a famous story
where a graduate student came somewhat
late to the lab and said but Professor
there's a revolution going on with
shooting in the streets this is in
Russia he said what difference does it
make when you've got work to do in the
laboratory next time there's a
revolution get up earlier okay so so
anyway you know and not an easygoing a
supervisor and he would do experiments a
little Ruffin in dogs like cut the
esophagus the path by which food goes
from the mouth to the stomach to
understand the role of the esophagus and
he found that even in those animals when
he placed food in the dog's mouth he
expected as about fundamental biologists
studying how digestion works that
nothing would happen but he noticed not
only with the dog salivate even though
the food will never make it to the
stomach but furthermore the stomach
juices the gastric juices that break
down food also were released within the
stomach even though the food would never
get there and then he got interested in
how it is that these things are driven
if they're not driven simply as a direct
response to the arrival of the food how
is it that the mayor site of the food or
the site of the person bringing the food
would drive the salivation
and what he called psychic secretions
you know because he was a biologist so
we expected basically he put the food in
the mouth there's some chemistry between
the food and salivation and here he's
here he's finding just seeing food just
seeing the person who would bring the
food was driving these fundamental
biological functions so there's a kind
of experiment that he would set up where
the dog would be there to be measuring
the amount of
elevation in some way or another and in
these kinds of experiments and I'll go
through this language a couple of times
in conditioning they've come up with a
servo cabbage to describe the pieces of
things that go into this kind of
learning so there's an unconditioned
stimulus which is food I mean you have
you start with that you want to eat food
and there's an unconditioned response
which is you salivate when you see the
food or if it's in your mouth that's
that's the beginning then you're going
to add what's initially a meaningless
stimulus in this case it could be
anything but in this case we'll say it's
a bell you ring a bell before the food
comes and you're going to get to a
conditioned response the animal will say
well the Bell predicts the food and I'll
salivate to the Bell itself even though
I'll never eat the Bell I learned that
it predicts the food is coming and so
you've created a new Association you
learn something new about the world that
a bell signal something that drives
salivation so that the two things are
sort of occurring next to each other in
time or what Aristotle talked about is
the law of contiguity the animal learns
that the Bell predicts the food coming
and so here's the basic idea at first
you know the tone does not drive
salivation right there's no reason to
salivate when you hear tone by itself
but as the animal discovers that the
tone predicts the food the tone predicts
the food the prom' predicts the food
then all of a sudden the animal starts
to learn that simply the tone alone will
drive the salivation now this stimulus
is conditioned and you have a
conditioned response that wasn't there
to start with it's very simple right you
learn the two are associated and now you
you begin to have a biological response
to the tone alone and typically what
happens is here's a learning curve
here's how often perhaps you salivate
and across trials you get you learn more
and more of that and you finally plateau
at some level of performance so a neat
thing about Pavlov is although there
weren't a lot of movies at his time
there is a little bit of film of him and
his actual dogs
so here's Pavlov's actual dogs
you
so um so we said conditioning is going
to do two magical things right it's
going to let us predict the future on
the basis of the past and it is very
simple experiment now the Bell predicts
the food coming up and the salivation
and it in Bews the world with meaning in
a sense the Bell now means here's dinner
right the Bell is not just a bell it's
something with meaning and significance
these are other example another example
of classical conditioning and it's got
some sophisticated properties you could
go well balloons popping water in your
face food for dinner that's a pretty
basic stuff but here's some
sophisticated properties of these as
learning mechanisms so one was already
talked about extinction that if the Bell
continues to ring and no food arrives
the learning gets weakened weakened and
disappears so you can learn something
and you can unlearn something because
it's no longer an effective predictor of
the future generalization is kind of
cute also so imagine the the frequency
of the stimulus is this just the
specific frequency of the tone well if
the tone is a little bit different you
know a little bit a little bit different
you might still think food is coming
right so stuff that you learn the
precise thing you'll be a little you'll
still respond if it's a pretty similar
tone and it's a tone gets more and more
different your response gets weaker and
weaker right that's smart
generalization I stay pretty close to
the tone I go for it I get further away
and not so sure okay it's not all or
none it's reasonably graded and
sensitive to the specifics of the
situation there's also one fascinating
thing which is here you acquire a
conditioned response it's extinguished
because you're only hearing that bell
there's no more food coming but when you
come back in and you'll often have a
kind of preserved recovery function of
that C s it's like it's lurking in you
somewhere okay it's like I have a mental
note it you know that this Bell might
mean food okay even though it was
extinguished it's still pretty
interesting stimulus so you have some
easily spontaneous recovery of these
kinds of learned conditioning it can
also be sophisticated in other ways and
let me give you a couple of examples you
can learn to discriminate between two
things we've only talked about one thing
so far Bell food but what if you what if
you have a black patch for example that
predicts food coming and a gray one that
predicts it's not coming you can
distinguish between those two you can
get second-order conditioning let me
show you that the dog learns that the
Bell predicts food now there's no food
presented for a while but there's a
black path
presented that you see presented with
the tone because you know the tone
predicts food the animal figures well
maybe this is a pretty good hint that
food is coming and after a while begins
to salivate to this one even though it
was never directly paired with the food
itself right so it's learning that you
know it's a transitive inference that
it's making you know if the bell
predicts it and the square goes with the
bell at some point I'll start salivating
for the square because that sounds like
a pretty good candidate for predicting
the future so that's pretty
sophisticated too you don't even have
food in this part but it's even more
sophisticated than that so look at these
two things and you can think about I'm
gonna let you think of us for a moment
here are two groups of animals or could
be people would work just the same way
as so here's the conditioned stimulus
and the unconditioned stimulus for
example a bell and the food the bell and
the food the Bell and the food one group
only gets bell food Bell food kinds of
pairings the other group gets the same
pairings but in between they'll have a
random food reward two random bells
random food random Bell now the pairings
are identical that's just shown in
orange this group will learn better and
faster more strongly than this group
even though they've had the identical
number of pairings why will this group
learn more slowly why will it even
though they have an identical number of
times they got the tone in the food the
tone of the food yeah tonight it's an
idea that is an extinction between I
think that's a good idea so that's a
very good answer extinction between
because when when you get this cs alone
your extent you're fighting the learning
but it's telling you the system is smart
right in the because of what it's kind
of doing is saying look asking us alone
not always a reliable predictor so I'll
learn it but I'm not going to believe it
that's so strongly right it's basically
because you're sticking extinction in
between those right you're also having
some trials with the food that aren't
predicted either right so it's like the
animal or you are learning what's a
really excellent signal and if there's
other stuff in there that gives the
signal not the same predictive power for
the future
you learn more slowly and less certainly
that relationship okay so that's pretty
smart too here's another way in which is
smart
and I'll tell you the phenomena and you
think about for why you think you know
learning might work this way in animals
and people so pretend there's a tone
that predicts food just like we've been
talking about all the way through food
stops and now you get a tone and a light
a tone and a light it so I'm going to
like the tone you know predicts is food
you're getting this part again without
food being presented and now you get the
light alone ok or everything's the same
but there isn't the initial learning
with the tone ok and then in the end
you're tested for the lights and what
happens is there's less conditioning to
the light here than here even though
you've seen a light and exact even
number of times why is the conditioning
to the light weaker here why is it
weaker here than here this is an
information problem for the brain to
solve about the truth of the world okay
well our interpretation is this tone
food tongue food you go good I got it
easy right now you get tone and light
together for a while and you go okay I
know the tone is really important the
light I don't know the tone was
perfectly good the light seems redundant
information aliy redundant okay so now
when it's a light alone you don't have
so much conditioning because he didn't
care about the light so much the food
had all the information you needed the
light was informational irredundant
right it was superfluous here you only
got trained with the tone and the lights
so you never made a bet on what's the
critical thing they both predicted
evenly so when the light comes by itself
that was always something that seemed
like a pretty good signal equally good
to the tongue so that's very
sophisticated that the animal learning
it or the human learning it is deciding
what's the information that's diagnostic
and what's the information that's
redundant
and it's conditioning across that right
so it's it's not just very simple
reflexes it's sophisticated learning and
here's okay so now I'm going to switch
gears so we're gonna have a
demonstration that involves the opposite
of fearful things like spraying water
and popping balloons but I can't tell
you too much about this but I can tell
you it's gonna be pretty pleasant okay
but I need somebody's willing to step
out of the room for a moment to do this
okay thanks yeah yeah you can safely
take off your jacket now right and
what's your name I'm Sam Sam okay try
not to listen if yeah possible okay so
so you guys are going to help me perform
instrumental conditioning and with it
we'll discuss what that is our job is to
have Sam come over here and pick this up
okay your job as a Sam comes in for
every action he takes a step this way
you know you play this game as a kid or
arm going in the right direction applaud
if he's doing something that gets him
closer to the goal of picking up the
brain and withhold your applause if he's
doing something that's taking him away
from that is that okay all right okay
so we're going to discuss what
instrumental conditioning is and then
we're going to slightly think
philosophically about whether this is
how you learn to do everything you get
to choose who the applause comes from
your parents your family your friends
you know medical schools and law schools
and graduate schools you get to choose
who the applause come from but how much
of our lives is responding to the
applause that we want to that we care
about so it will start more simply less
philosophically let's think about this
the examples we talk safari classical
conditioning all build on what feels
like a basic reflex salivating for food
flinching for water right okay so if we
asked somebody like why do you work hard
there's not going to be a very good
explanation in terms of those initial
reflexes right okay you're not flinching
you're not looking for food or water and
yet much of our life is involved in
endeavors that we learn where there's no
primary reflex that we can see in the
story and so operant or instrumental
conditioning those two words are
interchangeable is the way that
psychologists have tried to understand
those forms of learning and it began
something like this and this is from
Thorndike he put a cat into a puzzle box
I'll show you what the box looks like or
a sketch of it the cat had to unlatch a
door by pulling a latch so here's cats
in a box like this to get out which cat
wants to get out he or she has to push
this which will push the latch now it's
not obvious to a cat right wouldn't be
necessarily obvious to a person but
definitely the cat and the animal
learned it by trial and error so like
Sam did right and where is the where is
the unconditioned stimulus there's no
salivation or any reward like that so
stored I propose that you add people and
animals learn things by the consequence
of the response and the law of effects
is the consequence of a response
determines whether it is strengthened or
weakened you can be rewarded that will
strengthen response you can have no
reward that will weaken it you can be
punished that will greatly weaken a
response so here is the cat here's a
example of an academy cat to get out of
there as it tries different things but
with over repeated trials the cat can
get out really really fast and how
Thorndike you know by observation and
thinking thought about it was at the
beginning the animal wants to get out it
has no idea how to gets out so does
everything it can it scratches at the
bars it pushes up the ceilings at digs
at the florid howls oppress a moment it
presses a lever and that's good right
okay so here's different things that the
animal starts with thinking might be
good ideas but because it discovers with
repeated efforts with Prieta trials that
pressing the lever works these get
weakened this gets strengthened so the
consequence of response interments
whether it is strengthened or weakened
and now there's no salivating or reflux
or anything like that you can learn than
almost anything so this was picked up a
lot in the US which is a John Watson is
a famous name you'll see a kind of a
haunting a film of him performing this
kinds of stuff with infants in a kind of
a way that we would never allow ithaca
lee now it's not horrible but it's not
it's pretty bad okay but it's a famous
thing and you'll just get a feeling of
the power of this behaviorism that if
you study behavior instead of going in
you know for things like unobservable
thoughts that you would just do
observable actions and you wouldn't make
inferences about the mind that you can't
measure you make a stimulus you measure
the response and that's it no
fundamental differences between animals
and humans and you make laws that
describe the relationships between
stimuli in the environment and physical
behaviors that you can observe in
responses in that in the world that an
organism has so I'll come back to us a
little bit but one of the ways he wanted
to show that anybody could learn
anything because right now don't forget
the way we set this up anybody can learn
anything you can applaud anything right
so that makes you and you could teach
anybody anything by this perspective and
he went to show that he could teach an
infant who initially whose name was
little Albert that was his cover name
nobody actually knows his real name or
what happened to him and now well
nothing horrible happens in as far as we
know and now you would never do an
experiment like this I know this if you
have this in your notes this is a long
version of movies taken of this actual
sort of experiment that we wouldn't do
now and I'll show you the short version
in a couple minutes
where he got an infant
to become afraid of a rabbit that the
infant previously was not afraid of and
then the other huge name and this is BF
Skinner who worked at Harvard a
consequence of a response again fold
you know creates the responses that we
make in the world and him sense response
is not just the laboratory one but
things we do in the world with each
other and to each other and so the
classical conditioning the CS elicits
the CR the conditioned stimulus the Bell
elicits the conditioned response
elevation but an instrumental condition
see ours are emitted so and you can do
really anything that's in the range of
what an organism can do and then he
could show kind of impressively how you
might imagine a chain of these things
would lead to complex behaviors so he
would teach pigeons and other animals -
you know first to click to get a pellet
then where to click it then to where to
faced before you click it and he would
just keep adding little pieces shape the
pieces up from the first step to the
second step until you got pretty complex
behaviors ok so now I'm going to show a
slightly longer clip that has in it
these kinds of experiments and little
Albert it's kind of cool because in the
sense that I'm we can actually see films
of these sort of historical things which
often we don't get to do in various
science fields
so let's talk about this for one moment
so we can talk about primary reinforcers
like food thirst or paying things to go
with life right okay nothing injured who
the first it can talk about secondary
reinforcers that we know a lot about
money attention of other people praise
from other people admissions to places
you want to be admitted to promotions
when you want to get them there can be
positive or negative rewards and I'm
going to talk about one thing but just
for a moment you know the the
behaviorist said anybody can learn
anything right we'll come back to that
so that's that's been a big debate
whether you know anything can be equally
learned with any other thing and the
other thing that's a striking is you
know they be of Skinner particularly
said that we have an illusion of free
will that all we are learning these
things and we might as well you know get
over our illusion if we will
scientifically it's very hard for you
know even the best scientific
psychologists to tell you whether if we
will exist or not that's not something
that's easy for us to begin to imagine
how to measure but these kinds of
learning things are very impressive in
many ways and we'll talk about some of
that okay so let me talk to you about
one way in which for example casinos get
people to come back often and other
things in life okay without giving you
money every time because then they
wouldn't make money right so your book
talks about a number of examples of this
well just pick one partial reinforcement
so this means when do you get in these
animals when do you get a reward every
time or only a third of the time so of
course you learn faster if you get a
reward every time then if it's a third
of the time you're not quite as
impressed and excited but here's the
interesting thing if you stop giving the
reward these animals will go on for
quite a while before they extinguish
these animals will extinguish right away
and stop responding why will these
animals keep behaving for a time even
though you've entirely stopped the
rewards yeah
since they only got it like 30 percents
the time anyway it seems plausible to
them that it would go a couple more
times without them kidding yes since
they only got the answer mr. bright was
the only got a 30% of time so they're
gonna you know the first one or two
non-payments right they're gonna go well
it's coming up next okay a couple more
okay coming up soon until they finally
decide that the whole thing is over
right okay so so that's very interesting
the different reinforcement schedules
you know how they relate you might think
that well you always learn better if you
reward more but in some cases if you
want to get people to keep doing stuff
without direct reward partial
reinforcement is actually more powerful
okay now we're going to move into an
animal a dog experiments and then
directly to sort of thinking about
people in our own lives so this is a
famous famous experiment at University
of Pennsylvania from Seligman in this
case he used dogs it's been done with
many species in many circumstances and
he put them in a hammock so there's two
dogs on two sides of a thing that they
walked around and don't see each other
the dog a would periodically get a shock
you know and he could stop the shock by
pushing a panel near its nose okay soon
as the shock came he could turn his nose
and stop the shock dog be on the other
side of the divider would get exactly
the same shot he would stop at exactly
the moment that the first dog stopped it
but dog B had no direct control okay
equal number of shocks equal duration of
pain of objective pain if you want to
call it that way one animal has the
capacity to stop it the other does not
so that's the first part of the
experiment the second part of the
experiment they're put into a shuttle
box okay that looks it's just a box with
a big divider in the middle and they're
just hanging out there and then they
hear a tone at first it means nothing to
them and then comes a shock on the grid
on the floor okay and at first they
don't know what to do but after a while
they get smart like the cat and they
jump over the divider to the other side
and it's all okay so you can imagine
that when they hear the tone pretty
quickly that what do they learn to do
jump over the divider and stop the pain
and here's the remarkable thing for the
animals who had the experience that
pushing the panel stop the pain they
learned that pretty quickly for the
animals who could not stop the pain
initially they don't learn how to escape
when they could it's as if the animals
in Group B what they learned about life
you see it's painful and you can't do
anything about it right the animals in
Group A learned pain happens but I can
do something about it
so here's the animal you know at first
it doesn't know what to do it's getting
the shock but with trials the animal you
know the animal learns to jump and jump
so quickly that it doesn't have almost
any problem here's a tone boom it's out
of there okay it learns to avoid the
pain but what happens to the animals who
either had the escapable shock or the
ones right the ones who could poke their
nose they also learned this the ones who
could jump over there's nothing
preventing them from learning that they
just hit you know don't escape it's it's
what Seligmann called learned
helplessness that the animals learn from
the first experience their conclusion
was pain happens and I can't do anything
about it and then when they get in a
second situation where they can do a lot
about it they continue to feel helpless
and not do something about it it's like
a deep lesson about life like when do
you think you could make your situation
better
and when do you think there's nothing I
can do about it it's just bad bad bad
okay
and so there's ideas about that some of
this might be related to people who
struggle with depression but also other
things in life so here's the idea from
Seligman as an explanation of how we
have resilience the idea is that we all
you know get in some kinds of small
doses sometimes and tragically large
doses difficult things into our lives
how do we explain those difficulties
that have happened to us the setbacks we
have do we think they're internal to us
you know I'm the kind of person who has
bad luck I'm a kind of person that these
things happen to or is it external you
know somebody gave me a test you know
and what can I do about that but next
week the test is over and life will be
better okay is it global or specific
does it just seem miserable all over or
suggests you know one specific squirt in
the face this faculty member gave me
is it stable or unstable are bad things
just seeming to happen all the time or
is it one occasion and you can imagine
that people who believe that bad things
are internal global and stable will be
learn to be helpless everything seems
you know dark and hopeless people who
believe that things are external
specific and unstable think the next
time I can do better I can bounce back
from this and do better and it's not
only in terms of the spirit of people
and trying to get people to you know
bounce back from setbacks it's even
things like job applications so Seligman
did the following bet I don't even know
what corresponds to it before but there
used to be an era when people would go
knock on doors and try to sell you
insurance we don't do that anymore right
because if somebody comes our door
knocks at our door like calling the
police right but there was things were
more calm you know you need to open the
door and talk to or they would give you
cold calls which you don't get much more
anymore these days you guys are have you
ever even heard that phrase you know
that you'd work at some insurance
company to go here's some random
telephone numbers you call them up and
you try to sell them insurance you know
and it like usually get abused on the
phone where somebody slams into her but
these sales people they make commissions
and they keep going and he said let me
give my test he gave a questionnaire
whether people interpret the world one
way or the other way the resilient way
or there to learn help us this way and
you give your usual interview way for
picking salespeople and let me see who
picks a better salesperson and his
questionnaire picked a better
salesperson because if you have a sales
job where people often you know kick you
out and hang up on you you better be
pretty external specific and unstable in
your perception on things right because
when you have a hundred people who hang
up on you or close the door on you for
one sale you need to have a thick
resilient skin okay so lots of ways in
which I think this speaks to how do we
respond to the setbacks in our lives so
let me talk about some limits to
conditioning and and some of these I
think touch also on what are the values
by which we lead our lives it's not
going to be telling you that but you
know make you think about some of the
mechanics of what matters to you so let
me slide back for a moment so the
behavior is said everybody can learn
everything everybody can learn
everything in that sense it was seen as
a very democratic and egalitarian and
prosper effect everybody can learn
everything is just how you setup the
contingencies in the environment
and then Garcia did Annika famous
experiment where he had rats be get
shocks or receive a lithium chloride
which made them nauseous and they either
had a bright noisy stimulus or they
tasted some sweet water and even though
these things were arbitrarily combined
the rats learned who received shocked
learned to fear the bright noise the the
bright light of the noise and the rats
who got the lithium chloride made an
office learned to fear the sweet water
do you see why ok when we get nauseous
we think do we think like boy was noisy
last night what do you think when you
wake up in the morning you feel nauseous
what's the first thing you think yeah
something I ate right we're prepared for
internal nausea to think about food as a
risk and if it's a shock we're prepared
to think something out there ok so these
animals instinctively not on the basis
of the training instinctively you know
said if I feel a shock it's probably
related to this bright noisy stimulus
that warns me if I feel nauseous it's
related to the sugar water and they have
these opposite patterns of learning for
the stimulates as if these animals were
prepared to fear some things and not
others so it wasn't that everything
could be matched with everything and in
fact with humans they've done things
like show you pictures either of snakes
and spiders or flowers and mushrooms and
then those predicted a shock ok a small
shock to humans and they measure your
galvanic skin response and autonomic
response when you think you're getting
going to shock you start to get a little
sweaty ok and what they found was and
this will not shock you
they had better conditioning you more
quickly and completely learned that a
snake or a spider predicts a shock than
a flower or a mushroom right even though
objectively they were just as predictive
there's something about snakes and
spiders that gets us ready for scary
stuff ok and flowers and mushrooms they
really have to punish us before we think
they're evil
Warner signals ok so again a human
example of preparedness we don't learn
everything equally we prepare to learn
some things and not others eat ok same
thing with little Albert the child that
you saw you know
that kind of a film is a funny status
we'll talk about a few more things this
semester where that experiment why
should that experiment not be done yeah
yeah well you just you would never
terrorize a child right to scare the
child you know okay so weirdly enough
though these studies remain in the field
because since we can't do them again
because we know they're not right to do
we you know that we try to learn lessons
from them and you know so that we
learned something the rat worked okay he
got scared of a rat and then they got
scared of a bunny got scared of a cat
and anything animal anything furry but
if it gave him a wooden block that
didn't work okay it's not everything it
has to be prepared from that here's
another one that shows you that also
challenges simple ideas of do we always
learn simply to get a reward okay what
kind of learning might exist that's
reward 'less so there's three groups of
rats in a gold maze there's food rewards
every day for one group there's a happy
group there's no rewards for a grumbly
group there's a third group that gets no
reward for ten days and then it gets
reward okay so one reward all the time
reward never no reward for ten days and
then you start to get rewards all the
time and here's what happens to the
learning if you look at this green line
that's the food that gets rewarded all
the time so they learn to go
they make fewer errors so they can get
to the food faster if you look at the
group that's never rewarded this yellow
line is pretty steady it's like hanging
out no reason to go anywhere there's not
much going on
right look at the orange group for ten
days up to here they look like the
yellow line right not getting rewarded
I'm just going to saunter around there's
nothing interesting to learn here but
boom that first day that it's rewarded
by the twelfth day but just one day of
learning they're all caught up they're
all caught up so that people call this
late in learning that they were really
learning a lot about their environments
okay anyway even though it's of no use
at the moment and then the moment it
became valuable information boom they're
all caught up they didn't it's as if
they learned all this information that
was ready to go late and learning
stored-up just because they were in the
environment even though was unrewarded
and as we go around we often pick up
stuff even though there's no direct
reward and it's sometimes it turns out
to be useful people also love humans
including infants contingency this the
idea that we feel like we have control
over our world so here's a two month old
infant very young infant within a little
experiment where they put the infant in
a crib and above is a very colorful
color mobile and in one version they
when the infant moves his or her head
there's a switch in the pillow the
mobile moves and the infants are smiling
and cooing they love this is awesome
they move their head the thing moves
pretty impressive for two months all
they can do is wriggle their head right
they're not walking or anything they put
another group of infants in who have a
no switch and just periodically they
turn on the mobile there's no smiling no
cooing and they equate the number of
mobile turnings okay why is that well if
it's just because you like the mobile
turning then you should have both groups
be equalling and smiling or
disinterested but the rote there's
something fundamentally rewarding for
humans even at the age of two to feel
like they have control over their
environment and their pleasures and
that's that's not explained by
conditioning nobody's getting anything
more they're both seeing the equal
number of interesting turns but one
group feels like they're controlling
their environment here's another one
that I'm going to show you an animal
experiment where you can control things
but you can imagine in your own life and
you know in my life I see this all the
time
it's nice when something pleasant and it
happens in your life in your situation
gets better in some way right you get
you know you get a better iPad right
it's you know the how hard is it
emotionally when something gets worse
they take all your iPads away okay all
right yeah yeah when things are more
serious things when things you know get
worse often we feel pretty miserable and
here's a neat example of that so these
are rats in a experiment so everything's
controlled so here's one group of rats
this is how quickly they're running so
it's good to be high one groups in rats
is constantly getting one pellet a day
okay so they learn what to do and
they're sort of hanging out here doing
well a second group of rats is the
luckiest group of
they get eight pellets and they learn
more they flatten out okay so see you
get more reward that you drive the
behavior more that's not unexpected
the interesting thing are the two
contrast groups the contrast groups
start off with one or eight and then
after a couple days they're flipped
around so some started with one then
they got eight pellets others started
with eight then they got one does that
make sense okay so here's the contrast
group of eight you know they're learning
one go eight whoo okay all right there
they're happy okay they're getting eight
there likes got good look at the group
for whom life got worse I'm getting
eight I'm getting eight I'm getting
eight I'm getting one I'm getting one
I'm getting one it really stinks they're
actually worse than the groups that got
one all along right this is the lowest
line of all they're protesting this
stinks okay I was getting eight and I'm
getting one what a ripoff
you know what kind of world do I live in
right so the learning is protesting that
now by purely conditioning one why would
this group be worse they're still
getting a pellet okay but because
they're interpreting it as a world
that's going downhill as a worsening
situation they're less prone to learn it
they're sort of protesting and they're
learning things have been gotten worse
in the world a really interesting theme
along the Rhine of this reward an
unbelievable it's gotten a lot of
attention is delayed gratification you
know if you think about it and now this
is not purely scientific but there's a
theme delayed gratification is a
spectacular part of your life right
especially if you go through higher
education or maybe everything is like
this right yeah do a good job and
primary thing and you'll get to a good
middle school do a good job in middle
school you'll get to a good high school
do a good job in high school get to MIT
do a good job at MIT if you know you go
to med school or law school or become a
teacher where we want to do good job
good a good job of that and you'll get
to this thing do a good job of that you
know finally thank you very much you're
95 and you're done right okay all right
I mean I mean it's kind of like a you
know you guys are waiting a long time
between the efforts you're doing and
what you might consider a palpable
reward so here's a fantastically
interesting study from Walter Mischel
than at Stanford some years ago
he had four children were four to five
years old they were about 600 that were
studied they were mostly the children of
faculty and graduate students at
Stanford and they would come into a room
and the experiments slightly varied was
basically like this they would sit in
front of either a cookie or marshmallow
they used different rewards but imagine
it's a marshmallow or and the movie I'll
show you it's Oreo cookies and they were
told this and they tried to make this
the Walter Mischel the experiment
describes how he played with kids to try
to get to make the cookie look like reor
marshmallow like really awesome okay and
the kid would sit there the four or five
year old and they were told I'm going to
leave the room now there's a bell here
if you really want to eat that
marshmallow ring the bell and just eat
it but if you wait a while they didn't
tell him it was 15 minutes it was 15
minutes I'll come back and I'll give you
two delayed gratification I could have
one marshmallow now or if I hang in
there for 15 minutes and don't touch it
I can get to okay let me tell you the
result and then let me show a film of
this and when I was looking on YouTube
the Internet so there's a lot of posed
movies out there this is only one
building when I found from from Walter
Michelle himself that's a real movie of
real kids really doing this I don't know
why all the ones are posed on the out
there but here's something astounding
okay so these are all pretty similar
children children a faculty graduate you
know children varied how long they could
wait and if they took for example the
children who didn't wait very long they
could only wait 30 seconds until they
ate the cookie and they compared to the
children who would wait for the full 15
minutes to eat the cookie he's a four or
five year olds when they looked at them
at 18 and their SATs they got the
children who would wait 15 minutes
scored over 200 points higher which you
know is a lot that was in the days we
just had to SAT test it was 1,600 okay
and by many many measures in terms of
educational attainment in terms of
health and many measures the longer you
waited at age four or five the healthier
you were the better as eighty scores you
were the further you went in school
astounding correlations with real-life
stuff and people are stunned by this you
know partly it's gambling who knows what
goes into that at four or five
much as the influence of parents how
much is the influence of cultures and
genes who knows but that fateful moment
when the child goes for the marshmallow
are not correlates with incredibly
important outcomes in the future so um
let's see here we go
and you know right you know every
college I remember personally I like it
always was a battle like am I gonna have
fun or study I'm gonna have fun or study
there's so many chances to have fun and
there's so many pressures to study right
well studying can be fun learning is
okay how about when rewards harm again
these are things that are not strictly
predicted by conditioning I've three or
four more myths so rats love to run if
you would a hamster or anything like
that they love running wheels what if
you give them every time they run a food
reward okay then it turns out rats no
longer run for fun the only run when the
food is given okay if you start to
extinguish they stop running so what had
been a natural thing that seemed like a
whole lot of fun if it became the price
you pay for a reward all of a sudden
becomes a chore okay how about this a
widely studied cited experiment for mark
leper he took preschoolers so
four-year-old children who love to draw
lots of preschoolers loved to draw then
they started to give them every time
they drew a gold star you know every
time they get a reward what happened
when they stopped giving the gold stars
the kids stopped drawing this is
incredibly often cited in incredibly
interesting debates about whether
children in impoverished schools should
be given cash rewards for studying hard
okay there's lots of debates about
whether it's a good thing or not a good
thing and effective things are not an
effective thing the study is often cited
for arguing if you make something that
you should love like learning purely
rewarded the minute the reward stops it
becomes a complete chore okay
and you won't but we don't know how that
applies okay because we might read about
things like baseball players salaries
and it seems like there's a pretty good
relationship between performance and
salary right so it's it's not simply
that way in the world we know that often
rewards are associated with high
performance and promote high performance
so it's pretty complicated the last
slide is about a fantastic debate that
occurred here in many ways between BF
Skinner at Harvard and Noam Chomsky at
MIT which is in what senses language
learn by conditioning so here's here's
an example against it at one month
there's a switch inside a rubber nipple
hook to a tape recorder and when the
baby suck the tape plays this allows the
baby to perform to behave and they would
play syllables from different languages
and they may or may not be in their own
languages and by four days babies prefer
the languages that they are exposed to
and one of the questions is people said
well how do we get kids to learn
language from a behaviors perspective so
one of the things as a studied children
and they'll often young children will
say wrong things like mama isn't a boy
he a girl that's not good grammar right
and so there was an intuition that
parents would then go that's not good
grammar and sometimes parents do that
but when they did studies where they
recorded you know long sessions with
parents doing this parents almost never
corrected it was very rare okay
you may feel different from your own
record but statistically it's very rare
to collect too you know they often say
that that's right or something like that
so you know how is the child picking up
language if nobody's giving them rewards
and instruct it in terms of whether
they're right or wrong the idea is that
we can say an infinite number of
sentences well how can we possibly be
rewarded or conditioned for an infinite
variety of sentences how could that work
and and finally phenomenon over
generalizing you may know that children
will over generalize things like it's
because we usually end
Leedy to make a verb past tense right so
but some verbs don't work that way so
you would say my teacher held the rabbit
children often make these
over-generalized rules they say my
teacher holded the rabbit so obviously
they're learning a rule and then
applying it to an instance that if they
never hear because nope almost no adult
says that so they must be producing that
not on the basis of conditioning but
Chomsky argued on the basis of sort of
genetically prepotent ways in which we
learn language rules that we develop and
figure out language in the world I will
say that for those of you who happen to
interesting this topic there's been a
striking pushback on that and what
people call statistical learning so so
as much as this seemed like a done deal
10 years ago is I'm looking at there's a
little it turns out the truth might be
somewhere in the middle with some
genetic preach potentiation but also a
lot of learning from your environment
both so anyway so you can think as you
leave here you know what are the
applause that you listen to where's your
free will in your choice of what goals
you pursue and what matters to you and
how do you you know how does the world
attempt to teach you things that you
learn about what you want to do and why
you want to do them
you